we're coming together to reduce your
dependence on Russian energy
Putin has issued Russia's energy
resources to coerce and manipulate its
neighbors that's how he's used it he's
used the prophets to drive his War
Machine
that's why earlier this month I
announced the United States would ban
All Imports of Russian energy to make it
clear that American people would not be
part of subsidizing Putin's brutal
unjustified war against people in
Ukraine
at the time I noted that we were able to
take this step when others could not
because the United States is a net
exporter of energy with a strong
domestic industry and the United States
welcomed the European Union's powerful
statement early this month committing to
rapidly reduce its dependence on Russian
gas
today we've agreed on a joint game plan
toward that goal while accelerating our
progress toward a secure Clean Energy
Future
this initiative focuses on two core
issues one helping Europe produces
dependency on Russian gas as quickly as
possible
secondly reducing Europe's demand for
gas overall
to address the first point the United
States together with our International
Partners we're going to work to ensure
an additional 1 15 1 5 15 billion cubic
meters of liquefied natural gas LNG for
your this year
and as the year as the EU Works to
discontinue it by Russian gas well
before 2030. it will will also work to
ensure additional EU market demand for
50 billion cubic meters of LNG from the
United States annually by 2030.
to accomplish this the European
commission is going to work with the
member states
store gas across the continent to build
more infrastructure to receive LNG and
to take steps to increase the efficiency
of gas
this build out this buildup will occur
in a way that consists is consistent
with not in conflict with the zero Net
Zero climate goal we should that we're
shooting for
the transatlantic partnership stands
stronger and more united than ever
and we are determined to stand up
against Russia's brutal War this war
will be a strategic failure for Putin as
you know we aim to reduce this
dependency on Russian fossil fuels and
to get rid of it
and this can only be achieved
through of course first of all
investment in Renewables
but also through additional gas supplies
including LNG deliveries so we want as
Europeans to diversify away from Russia
towards suppliers that we trust that our
friends and that are reliable
well that's the latest from Brussels we
can now see the latest from Sky Sally
Lockwood she's in Nave in Western
Ukraine and she says this deal is a
significant step towards moving away
from the world's Reliance on Russian
energy
significant development that agreement
that the U.S has reached with the EU in
the last hour to supply liquefied
natural gas to Europe of course that
we've really struggled to see a unified
approach among many European leaders
given some countries are more reliant on
Russian energy than others but the EU as
a whole Imports around 40 percent of its
gas from Russia to power its homes
businesses factories and this is a
signif significant step towards moving
away from that Reliance on Russian
energy of course this is something that
president zielinski has repeatedly
called for a boycott on Russian energy
but it's not simple it's not a silver
bullet this is something though that
they hope to like roll out starting at
this year although they don't have the
same distribution pipelines uh in terms
of importing natural gas by sea into
Europe so there are estimates that they
could only manage to it felt around
two-thirds of the supply that Russia
already provides to Europe in terms of
its gas supplies and it could also end
up being far more expensive for
consumers